This is the Nike Flight Ball.
It has 30 percent truer flight than our previous ball.
Consistency, consistency, consistency.
Some of the top players will be knocking the ball around 60 miles an hour.
They want to know where they're putting it,...
...so the ball has got to keep pace with, or if not, faster than the game.
Footballers.
A ton of footballers.
We listen to the voice of the athlete, gather that information,...
...and then put coordinates and such into the robot.
That robot allowed us to continuously test...
...and have the same track system we had on pitch in the lab.
When a smooth surface passes through the air,...
...the air will grip that surface and cause distortion.
When we apply the AerowSculpt technology,...
...it allows us 30 percent truer flight and consistency that we're looking for in the ball.